THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> WITH THE PLAN TO IMMEDIATELY
PROVIDE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN DEBT RELIEF STIMULUS
RIGHT NOW.
THE LEGISLATION PASSED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE CALLS FOR AN
IMMEDIATE $10,000 FORGIVENESS OF
STUDENT LOANS.
IT SHOULD BE DONE IMMEDIATELY.
I AM CONSIDERING DEALING WITH
SOME DEPTH REDUCTION.
I AM NOT CONSIDERING $50,000 OF
DEBT REDUCTION.
BUT I AM IN THE LOOKING AT
WHETHER THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
DEBT FORGIVENESS.
>> ARE YOU CLOSE TO MAKING A
DECISION ON THE DATA?
>> YES.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
EXPECTED TO KEEP HIS WORD ON
CANCELING STUDENT DEBT, SO GET
READY FOR A SUBSIDIZED LIBERAL
ARTS DEGREES.
ANNOUNCING THE DECISION TO RAISE
$10,000 TO STUDENT LOANS FOR
EARNERS MAKING LESS THEN
$125,000 PER YEAR.
THAT'S A LOT.
IT'S A MOVE THAT ONE ACTUALLY
ERASED DEBT, BUT INSTEAD
TRANSFER THE BURDEN TO YOU, THE
TAXPAYER.
EVEN SOME LIBS THINK IT IS A BAD
IDEA.
AS OBAMA'S TREASURY SECRETARY
LARRY SUMMERS POINTS OUT
"STUDENT LOAN DEBT RELIEF IS
SPENDING THAT RAISES DEMAND AND
INCREASES INFLATION.
IT CONSUMES RESOURCES THAT COULD
BE BETTER USED HELPING THOSE
THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON DID NOT
HAVE THE CHANCE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AND WILL BE INFLATIONARY
BY RAISING TUITION."
THE BIDEN SPIN TEAM TRYING TO
DOWNPLAY THAT NARRATIVE.
>> THERE'S BEEN BEEN A LOT OF
COMMENTARY RAISED ABOUT
POTENTIAL INFLATIONARY EFFECTS
OF DEBT INFLATION.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO WHEN YOU ARE
MEASURING THIS OUT IS LOOK AT
THAT CANCELLATION AND ALSO DEBT
TO RESTART, THAT IS THE END OF
THE PAUSE AND RESTARTING
PAYMENTS.
BOTH OF THOSE HAVE TO BE
FACTORED IN WHEN YOU ARE TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL IMPACT
ON OVERALL INFLATION.
>> Jesse: BUT JOE BIDEN'S PLAN
IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE FAR
LEFT, CORI BUSH SOUNDING OFF.
"STUDENT DEBT IS MERELY A TRUE
BILLION DOLLARS CRISIS POTUS
MOST #CancelStudentDebt ."
BUT EVERYBODY SHOULD SEE IT FOR
WHAT IT IS, A BRIBE, THEY HAVE
SOURED ON THE PRESIDENCY 21% OF
18-30-YEAR-OLDS GIVE HIM THE
STAMP OF APPROVAL, IS THIS JUST
A QUICK WAY FOR HIM TO WIN THEM
BACK.
DANA, IF YOU TAKE OUT A LOAN ANY
OF OPERA DEMOCRATS COMING IN
MIGHT GET THAT LOAN PAID BACK BY
US.
>> Dana: WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS
COMING BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
KEPT KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD.
EVEN HE HAD SAID THIS IS JUST
FOR POLITICS LAST JANUARY.
EVERYBODY IS SAYING THIS IS A
BAD IDEA EXCEPT WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SAYING, NO, REALLY,
COME WITH US AND OVER TO THE
FARTHER LEFT SIDE AND WE WILL
MAKE A BIG DEAL OF IT.
THEY ARE BASICALLY WRITING OFF
THE MIDDLE CLASS AND THE
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS.
COMPLETELY WRITING THEM OFF.
47% OF AMERICANS HAVE A
FOUR-YEAR DEGREE.
ONLY 13% HAVE GRADUATE DEGREES,
BUT 50% OF THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
IS HELD BY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
GRADUATE DEGREES.
SO WHAT HAPPENS TO THE GUY WHO
TOOK OUT A LOAN TO GET AN F150
SO THAT HE COULD TAKE HIS TOOLS
AROUND?
THAT THAT WILL NEVER BE
CANCELED.
AND IT DOES NOT GET CANCELED, IT
GETS TRANSFERRED TO SOMEONE
ELSE, WHICH TRANSFERRING THE
DEBT TO THE GUY WITH THE F-150
IS ALSO INFLATIONARY.
WHY ARE WE INCREASING --
WHY ARE WE MAKING A MOVE THAT
WOULD INCREASE INFLATION AT THIS
TIME?
WHY DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
IT IS ALSO SOMETHING CONGRESS
SHOULD DO.
IT IS AN ILLEGAL MOVE AND
UNETHICAL IT IS IMMORAL, AND
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET TO THE
POLITICAL PAYOFF THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR, THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO GET THE P.R. SPIN.
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THE POLICY PAIN
AND NOT GOING TO SATISFY THE
LEFT, AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
SATISFY ANYBODY ON THE RIGHT.
>> Jesse: PROBABLY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT, SO IF YOU HAVE A GRADUATE
DEGREE IN PHILOSOPHY AND ARE
MAKING $124,000 A YEAR
>> Tyrus: YOU HAVE BEEN DOING
YOUR RESEARCH.
WELL PLAYED, SIR.
SOCRATES HAS SAID ON MANY
OCCASION "IF IT FLOATS LIKE A
DUCK THAN IT IS PROBABLY A
DUCK."
I AM EXCITED THAT AT LEAST HE IS
MARKING UP A LITTLE BIT.
I WISH HE HAD THE BACKBONE THAT
HE DID 20 YEARS AGO OR EVEN TEN
YEARS AGO WHERE HE COULD
ACTUALLY SAY, HEY, THIS IS A BAD
IDEA.
WE SAID THAT WE WERE NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
SO AT FIRST IT WAS ALL, THEN 50,
NOW TEN.
BY THE END OF NEXT WEEK IT WILL
BE LIKE $17.30.
SO WE WILL JUST KEEP GETTING
LOWER AND LOWER AND LOWER AND
THEN HE WILL SAY, LOOK WHAT I
DID.
I GOT YOU GUYS $0.14 BACK,
BECAUSE $10,000 ON THE STUDENT
LOAN ISN'T ANYTHING ANYWAY.
SO THAT'S REALLY GOING TO COVER
THE LATE FEES, BECAUSE MOST OF
THEM HAVE NOT PAID IT.
AND THE FACT THAT IT IS GOING TO
60% OF THE EARNERS SO THAT THE
LITTLE GUY ONCE AGAIN IS BEING
FORCED TO PAY FOR THE BIG GUYS
STUFF.
SO IT IS LIKE FOR HIS LENDERS,
HIS DONORS.
HERE'S THE MONEY BACK AND
HOPEFULLY HE WILL GET IT
FORWARD.
>> Jesse: SO THIS WAS SCRANTON
JOE, THE MIDDLE-CLASS GUY WITH
THE LUNCH PAIL AND THE AMTRAK
TICKET.
DOES HE REALIZE THAT HE IS JUST
HELPING OUT THESE GRADUATE
DEGREE --
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY A BAD WORD
ABOUT THEM.
I WANT TO SO BADLY.
>> AND I HAVE A GRADUATE DEGREE
MYSELF.
YES, AND I TOOK OUT LOANS, SEAN
HAS A LAW DEGREE AND TOOK OUT
LOANS, 20 YEARS, NINE KIDS, WHO
IN CONGRESS IS COMPLAINING THE
MOST ABOUT THESE?
IT IS AOC DOES NOT HAVE ANY
KIDS, AND SHE IS COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE LOANS.
AGITATING AND TRYING AS YOU SAID
DANA TO GET MORE PEOPLE ON HER
SIDE.
I REALLY THINK THAT OUR COUNTRY
NEEDS TO GO BACK TO THE PLACE
WHERE YOUR WORD, YOUR HANDSHAKE,
YOUR SIGNATURE MEANT SOMETHING.
YOU SIGNED YOUR NAME.
YOU SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO
IT, DO IT.
AND I WILL PAY THIS, IT FELT SO
GOOD WHEN WE PAID IT OFF.
BUT NOW I KIND OF FEEL LIKE A
CHUMP.
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO GET
IT, AND $10,000 IS A LOT.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY IF SOME
MONEY SOME OF THE PAGE THAT OFF.
>> PEOPLE STILL WANT MORE PEOPLE
STILL HAVE TO PAY.
>> Jesse: PURE ENOUGH.
I DON'T MEAN TO DISPARAGE PEOPLE
WITH GRADUATE DEGREES.
>> Jessica: HE MEANT TO ONLY
DISPARAGE ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Rachel: DON'T END
>> Jesse: I'VE NO GRADUATE
DEGREES, EVERYBODY ELSE IN MY
FAMILY HAS A GRADUATE DEGREE,
HOW ABOUT THAT.
SO FINANCIALLY SUCCESSFUL,
EMOTIONALLY, NOT SO SUCCESSFUL.
SO TELL US WHY THIS IS A GOOD
MOVE.
>> Jessica: THAT WAS NOT MY
INTENTION.
IT IS CERTAINLY THE WRONG TIME
FOR THIS MOVE.
AND I AM FASCINATED BY THE GAME
THAT GOES ON WITH LARRY SUMMERS.
HE IS GOD'S GIFT TODAY.
HE DOES NOT KNOW WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT TOMORROW.
HE WAS ON BARRY WEISS' PODCAST
OVER THE WEEKEND.
AND WE WERE LISTENING TO IT ON A
CAR RIDE YESTERDAY.
>> Jesse: SOUNDS LIKE A FUN
RIDE.
>> Jessica: IT WAS A LONG
ANYWAY.
AND HE KNOWS WHAT ROLE HE PLAYS
IN THIS, RIGHT?
HE HAS BECOME THIS GRANDFATHER
OF DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
OBVIOUSLY KNOWS WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT AND NO ONE CAN
POINT TO THE CLINTON YEARS AND
SAY THAT THEY WERE BAD.
REPUBLICANS EVEN LIKE THE
CLINTON YEARS.
SO HE HAS BONA FIDE TO GO ON THE
OBAMA YEARS AND THEN THE FACT
THAT HE PUSHED BACK AGAINST
BUILD BACK BETTER, BUT WAS THE
ONE WHO HAS TAXED AT PERSONALLY
CALLING JOE MANCHIN TO SAY THE
SKINNY BELT, THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
AND I THINK WHEN YOU ARE ON THE
ASCENSION AND DEMOCRATS ARE
CERTAINLY DOING BETTER THAN THEY
WERE A MONTH AGO, TWO MONTHS
AGO, AND BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING
IS TAKING UP ABOUT 40% NOW, YOU
JUST DELIVERED THE BIGGEST CLIMB
IN ACTION WE HAVE HAD IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES THE
PROGRESSIVES, THE FAR LEFT
REALLY HAPPY.
CORI BUSH, AOCS, THAT IS ENOUGH
HEADING INTO THE MIDTERM.
WHEN YOU BRING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS UP AND IT ALLOWS PEOPLE IN
THE MIDDLE AND CERTAINLY
REPUBLICANS TO CAMPAIGN ON THE
IDEA THAT YOU'RE JUST GIVING
MONEY BACK TO TOP 60% OF EARNERS
AND IT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THE PROBLEM WHICH IS
TUITION.
INSTITUTIONS HAVE NO INCENTIVE
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT --
IT'S LIKE HIGHWAY ROBBERY HOW
MUCH THESE DEGREES COST.
>> Rachel: YOU JUST BROUGHT UP
THE TUITION, LOOK WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE CLIMATE BILL.
THEY SAID WE WILL GIVE YOU A
SUBSIDY ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
THAT SAME DAY THEY RAISE THE
PRICE OF GM AND FORD OF THOSE
VEHICLES BY THE SAME AMOUNT OF
THE SUBSIDY.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SAYING
TUITION PRICES WILL GO UP
$10,000 TOMORROW?
>> Jessica: LOOK AT HOW HARD
THE UNIVERSITY'S PUSH BACK
AGAINST THE PROVISION IN THE
BILL THAT WOULD HOLD THEM A
LITTLE BIT MORE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE HUGE COST THAT THEY ARE
SITTING ON.
SOME PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS COULD
PAY AND MAKE IT FREE FOR THE
REST OF THE TIME, THAT'S HOW
WELL HARVARD HAS MANAGE THEIR
MONEY.
I KNOW WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
HARVARD.
>> Dana: BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
POLLS EVER SINCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION STARTED DO YOU
THINK THAT THIS PRESIDENT CARES
ABOUT THINGS THAT YOU CARE
ABOUT?
IS PULLING ON THAT HAS BEEN
REALLY BAD AND THEN WHEN YOU ARE
LOOKING AT FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT THERE
BASICALLY BEING TOLD THAT THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT IS
SOMETHING GREAT THAT THEY HAVE
GAS AND GROCERIES THAT WILL GO
DOWN IN PRICE WHEN THEY REALIZE,
NO, ACTUALLY IT WAS ALL FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE LAST REMARK I
THINK THE EXACERBATING FEELING
THAT THERE IS THE PROBLEMS AS
THE LITTLE GUY HAS TO PAY FOR
THE BIG GUY.
>> Tyrus: TRYING TO SOLVE THE
WORLD WITH FIRST WORLD PROBLEM
SOLVERS AND MOST OF US LIVE ON
THE EARTH WHERE WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH REAL STUFF.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE A GRADUATE
DEGREE?
>> Tyrus: I DO NOT, I AM WITH
YOU AND I AM THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PERSON IN MY FAMILY AS WELL.
>> Rachel: ALL OF YOUR
RELATIVES